pokemon scarlet and violet get a
boatload of new info and sonic frontiers
gets gameplay shown for the first time
ah yes a new pokemon trailer you know
what that means memes memes and more
memes one might even say that this is
the best part of a new pokemon game's
rollout today gamefreak debuted a new
trailer giving us an even better look at
the new region and the creatures we'll
see in the next mainline pokemon game
the trailer showed off the mouse-type
pawnee the plant smallif and the very
good pig lechonk the internet loves le
chong the trailer also debuted the new
legendary pokemon exclusive to each
version and i know for a fact i'm going
to say both of them wrong korreiden from
scarlet and miraden from violet but
pocket monsters aren't the only thing we
got to see we also got a glimpse of some
of the new human characters and for the
first time in series history the
professors will be split up into the
respective versions of the game as for
your friendly rival this time around it
is a young girl named nimana a press
release alongside the trailer detailed
that the game will allow free co-op
exploration for up to four players
although specifics on how this works
like what happens when someone enters a
battle for instance remains a mystery
pokemon scarlet and violet are set to
release on november 18 2022 let me know
in the comments what you thought of the
new trailer and which version of the
game you're planning to pick up in
november i'm leaning towards scarlet due
to the more futuristic design of its
legendary pokemon and its professor i
just really wish we got more information
on that co-op but november is a ways
away there's still time for more
information to come out i also wish the
game didn't look so rough around the
edges but that's a topic for another
video instead let's talk about gameplay
from another franchise i loved in my
youth sega showed off some sonic
frontiers gameplay today that featured
the iconic hedgehog racing around a
puzzle-filled island described as an
open zone game by sega sonic's latest
adventure will see him doing far more
than just running around the environment
as he'll finally be able to put his
climbing skills to good use like
yesterday's teaser the new gameplay had
a healthy mix of speed rail grinding and
platforming to show off as well now i
know opinions on 3d sonic games can be a
bit divisive however even if you're
leaning towards the hating it side you
can't deny that this game just looks
beautiful it also looks huge and kinda
empty so i'm hoping there's a lot to do
besides just the puzzles we've seen i
mean i'm sure there is but just you know
fingers crossed and the good news is
while we all wait for new information on
sonic and pokemon we can distract
ourselves with diablo immortal the game
has arrived a day early on mobile even
though pc players will have to wait
until tomorrow june 2nd in order to play
however don't get too distracted by
immortal and forget to grab the bioshock
collection today is the last day to
scoop it up for free on the epic game
store so right when this video is over
and you are done looking at my face
go claim it even if you don't have an
epic game store account or a pc go into
the browser you can make an account
there and i'm pretty sure you can claim
the game in browser don't miss out
alright
grab it i'll see you tomorrow